hey oz how did you get to the game today
a good team great team 100
yep
what'd you have for dinner last night
100 of 100 yeah you're dead of course
100 or whatever 100 was
you know what
can you just do me a favor and tell me
one specific thing like just one
actual original observation that you had
about today's game the game that you won
almost single-handedly do you think that
you could do that oz oh 100 oh god damn
it
[Music]
welcome back to the marty jepson show
i'm morty jefferson we're here today
continuing our conversation with
unbelievable mega superstar young
business
now young business i got to tell you
we've been tiptoeing around a particular
subject all day and i think it's time to
broach it
you've separated recently with your your
actress girlfriend tina bouquet no and
everybody wants to know more what's
wrong we ain't going to talk about that
i'm not here to talk about that i just
want to hear your side of the story you
don't want this one i told y'all
in your music young business you do a
lot of fun
and lots of people understand that
you're talking about your own more
experiences more your fans i ain't gonna
like to know how much is going on with
you and team what no you don't know i
don't want to know what you want to know
i just want to click on the clip all i
want to do is i want to hear your side
of the story
there's no need for the interview to be
over interviews over young [ __ ]
young venus there's no need for the
language or any of this we can just sit
down i told you i'm not going to talk
about that do you want to talk about the
album because i'll be more than happy to
talk about the album this is the c word
more it looks like it's well on its way
to going platinum or cd
lewis
go well on its way to going platinum we
can talk about this as kind of
what would you say in here it's fine
with me you want to talk about the i'm
going to talk about the um how about the
tanks of truth
take some truth is that a treatise on
the uh the conflict with isis i mean
would it would talk to me about this
what young business please i'm begging
y'all sit down take a deep breath oh and
let's discuss go let's discuss the album
it's done mort
it's done
okay
okay so
you brought this on yourself more
business i would really put it on
yourself young business young business i
would really love it if you had a seat
and we could just talk together about
anything anything you want we don't i
won't mention tina's name again young
business
youthful commerce how does where does it
go to louis
no get the get
off me louis louis go leave it be you're
exacerbating the situation it's attached
to
it's probably coming off it's just been
a lot of fun the chord is blending in
with the color of the carpet
okay i just think that young business
why don't you drop the mic there and
have a seat this is what we used to call
back in the army of fubar see now
okay let me just tell you no don't don't
get involved to get you out of here and
amy please can we just why is it
listen here okay you know if you let go
of it
hey let me get in there don't get in it
don't see trying to get around don't
step on my jacket
1500 jacket [ __ ]
what is getting you know why do we have
black cords and a black carpet
all right well you want i told y'all
i wasn't gonna load louis
i swear to god we're gonna take care of
it
just
can i may i help you don't touch the
jacket i'm sorry i'm trying to walk you
here raise raise your knees right here
you got to get now hold on i got the
sight let's see
you know what here here's what no okay
have a seat here put your family right
here don't say fanny right there don't
all right
how you do you do it you do this every
don't you ain't taking the pants off
nicole goddamn it where is jerry this is
something right here same sound guy for
27 kids
vanished all right all right all right
all right no calls
take all right louis louis
hold that don't do anything but hold
that
okay no no you gotta put no you gotta
take the no you can't take the fans off
over the shoes you can't take the pants
off over the shoes louis louis get your
white ass out the [ __ ] you ain't
spanish
helping
right all right i'm taking the shoes off
okay left one first
all right well do whatever you want then
fine
thank you one
two thank you i told y'all i wasn't
gonna talk about that
we'll be right back with alec baldwin
welcome back we're here talking with
all-star shooting guard charlie sanders
about his amazing career now charlie you
grew up in a tough neighborhood didn't
you that's right
drugs violence
my whole life i had to deal with
adversity and that continued when you
went on to the pros that's right you
know fines injuries everything no matter
how big a star i am
i'm always gonna be dealing with
adversity adversity johnson what's your
take on this i don't know girl i just
like
come on adversity deal with me dogs
always
wherever we go
it's come on no don't don't drink my
water don't drink my water at first you
leave me something leave me a sip leave
me a sip dab come on man
deal with me
this
he doesn't i'm sorry
no he doesn't pick up social cues
what here we go
[Applause]
twister
come on are you okay no
i am here with osman says buckshank the
rookie out of stanford university who is
undoubtedly the mvp of today's game with
an interception that he runs back for a
touchdown in the last 30 seconds of the
contest osmotes can you walk us through
what happened on that last play it was
amazing yeah we knew we had to go out
there give 100
we executed it just went our way today
and was the quarterback giving you any
clues uh today oz uh it looked like you
knew that ball was gonna be there what
was happening knew we wanted to have
some fun you know execute play one
quarter at a time give a hundred percent
i'm saying okay okay you know let's just
let's talk about last week's game uh uh
you guys lost a heartbreaker give me
your state of mind then versus now i
wanted to do play-by-play give it a
hundred percent execution-wise execute
okay
i'm gonna ask you something completely
different that's not about football look
at me oz just look at me for a second
i'm gonna ask you a question right here
that a boy so you and your wife recently
had right here stay with me you and your
wife recently had twins okay how does it
feel to be a new dad
you know we wanted to stay as a team
execute give a hundred percent play by
play okay you know what i'm just i'm
just gonna
i'm gonna do a little test right now uh
hey oz how did you get to the game today
they're good team great team 100
yep
and what'd you have for dinner last
night 100 of 100 yeah you're dead of
course 100 or whatever 100 was
you know what
can you just do me a favor and tell me
one specific thing like just one
actual original observation that you had
about today's game the game that you won
almost single-handedly do you think that
you could do that oz oh 100 oh god damn
it
what do we do
they told us at the station to come down
here and fill time but uh there's no
story here
in this neighborhood there's always a
story
here give me the name of a mythical
creature mythical cr i don't trust me uh
i don't know a pegasus pegasus perfect
just roll
watch and learn
everybody can stay in my house if they
want to hi there rick nicklesby channel
6 news we've had reports of a pegasus in
the area has anybody seen anything like
that oh yeah man i've seen the pegasus
i've seen it you know every day yeah i
see the dude man we both seek that
pegasus yeah i started with my own two
eyes man that horse had a big old
snakehead on top of it ain't
curiosity has brought out large crowds
to see the alleged pegasus in this south
lennox neighborhood oh look there it is
i'm gonna find it
break it
and then ride it to the pegasus treasure
residents say the creature resembles
this amateur sketch kick the [ __ ] out my
car
city's got to pay for that too i ain't
got no coverage no pegasus [ __ ] he
landed on my roof man look at my root
man he busted it up he busted the whole
thing up man yeah he been he but he been
sitting up there every day while many
revel in the possibility of seeing the
winged horse others are not so welcoming
i i just know this neighborhood will be
better if that pegasus is put down i
tell you this god ain't putting our
wings on no horse now see if this was a
white neighborhood
animal control would be up in here with
a pegasus trap that's right they can't
take our pegasus this is all pegasus
hey man why are you interrupting me i'm
trying to talk about the pegasus
don't be disrespecting the packages
[Music]
yes we're here live on the scene in
south lennox where riots have broken out
over the alleged appearance of a flying
horse
what a mind-blowing finish to an
incredible game tonight with charlie
sanders winning the game in literally
the last second uh unbelievable truly
spectacular charlie sanders how does it
feel hey y'all want to say something to
everybody watching yo you can do
anything anything's possible the world
is yours charlie did you think that that
game was going to end that way tonight
yo there are no limits all right you can
swim across the atlantic you can jump
real high and touch the mold fantastic
charlie sanders fresh off of his uh
victory uh just feel like he's ready to
touch the moon i can fly
anybody can fly if you believe in
yourself the way i believe in myself
tonight you will fly and what's next for
charlie sanders and the orange friends
you can actually fly
no no no well not literally yes
literally kids young kids i want you to
go up on your roots right now wait what
fly into the night sky
okay people will see you flying and you
can do anything you can do anything okay
well we we just want to remind the kids
that of course you cannot actually fly
kids
through that negativity man hey boys and
girls ages eight through twelve yo don't
let nobody ever tell you what you can
and cannot do all the preteen children
out there listen to my voice you are
immortal
okay well obviously we understand that
charlie is super excited right now and
that no one is actually immortal no
kids
you could turn yourself into a car and
have a friend drive you onto the freeway
okay no well that's just a metaphor
of childish innocence get a friend on
your back and make a b-line for the next
ramp to the freeway y'all okay don't do
it he's a freeway he's speaking
fingernails
once you get there ain't nothing
figurative about this you will turn into
a robot first and foremost i just want
to say to the 12 families who lost
children
i'm sorry
my statements were irresponsible
i
have subsequently looked up the terms
literally
and metaphorically
and found that
whereas i was not incorrect
they did not mean what i thought they
had meant
this is the fight everybody's been
waiting for but when i get andre in the
ring man it's gonna be cruel and quick
because it's gonna be like one two one
two boom and you out man
you claudius louis i'm gonna right in
the ass yeah i'm gonna bend you over and
right in the ass
all right you know what
andre he like to be trying to get into
his opponent's hairs by saying crazy
stuff he ain't gonna get into my head he
ain't gonna get into my head no i'm not
gonna get in your head i'm going to get
in your ass just like i said just right
up in there in that tiny little
minuscule ass of yours this is what's
going to happen i'm going to take you to
a nice high fancy highfalutin restaurant
and i'm going to buy you things whine
and dine you and we're going to find
some things that we have in common and
they're gonna become inside jokes to us
and then we're just gonna laugh about
them in the taxi all the way to your
house where i'm gonna
in the ass
oh okay now
just me
personally i've never you know i never
seen andre take it that far
before
but
what whatever yeah whatever i'll tell
you whatever whatever i'm finally gonna
feel comfortable taking you out to
dinner parties and then all of our
friends will also couples they're just
gonna laugh at us because we're that
couple that holds hands all the time let
me tell you something claudius we love
each other so very much that no matter
how tired i am no matter how much
[ __ ] i've dealt with over the day
i'm just gonna leave it at the door when
i put you in the ass okay you know what
man it's time for you to stop all that
nonsense right now all right
he just said he's gonna take me to
dinner parties he did say dinner parties
you know
gonna snuggle on the couch every night
i'm gonna let you pick the movie even
though you always pick the movie then
i'm gonna take you out for a walk on the
beach and the moonlight's gonna bounce
off of your scalp and i'm just gonna
kiss you so tenderly while the waves
break and then right there right then
i'm gonna
win the sandy ass all right it's time
for you to shut you up for a minute
yes it is time it's time for you to shut
your mouth we're gonna spend the golden
year together yeah yeah i'm gonna
support you all the way through your run
through city council yeah that's right
you're gonna be tired and exhausted
overworked but we're still gonna find
the energy to go antiquing on the
weekend oh yeah then you're gonna be on
your deathbed and you're gonna be
sitting there and you're gonna be dying
i'm gonna be right beside you and i'm
gonna be crying and right at that moment
when you cross over from this world into
the neck
[Applause]
you in the air
man i wish you tried oh you do i wish
that you were
[Music]
no
i love the village as much as the next
guy but i'm telling you if we continue
to self-segregate ourselves the entire
gay community is going to continue to be
marginalized i was just saying this to
claudius the other night right after i
put him in the ass yeah he did he did
anyway enough politics cheers everyone
[Music]
rick nicholsbee reporting live from a
gruesome scene a cult known as qet or
quest for eternal truth has apparently
taken their own lives in a mass suicide
police confirmed that cyanide-laced
cherry kool-aid was also on the premises
excuse me hi rick nicholsbee channel six
hi are you two from the neighborhood oh
yes
yes
yeah
okay were you two members of the cult
that lived here the co what cult was
this a cohort i had no idea this was a
cult why well i won't say the term cult
it's a little judgmental i would say the
same thing yeah not knowing the full
doctrine well apparently they believed
that there was a spaceship waiting for
them behind the moon okay well you know
that that still is really possible and
it's possible right i mean who knows
what is out there in the universe
okay well it appears they killed
themselves in order to board the ship
right and that's where we disagreed with
them right there or would have we would
have disagreed with them had we been
there on on our departure day their
departure day their departure day which
is the day that they
did this
i mean that's what you could call it if
you wanted to i ain't in no cult though
i mean what i always wondered is how or
am starting to wonder since you brought
this to our attention why if there was a
space ship in the sky why wouldn't it
just beam up up beam them up right
sisters just beam them up why can't you
just beat them up alive why you got to
be dead to get beamed up you know what
i've been saying that for weeks seconds
for seconds because because you rick
nichols b you told us that uh you know
and that's how i knew because seconds
like 50 seconds ago you said it i didn't
know anything about it until you would
said it because i ain't in no code okay
well then why would someone join a cult
dramatically leadership
you know like a compelling
person
i mean hypothetically they could have
had tacos on tuesday which would have
been a draw i mean i would have been a
plus
okay so this is a tragic day for this
community and for the members of the
quest for earthly truth i'm rick
nicholsbee reporting
you see yep you see
everybody jump the gun
and that's what we're here to say is
that we are the new black panther party
what's the biggest problem facing the
movement
well you know we supposed to be in this
era of so-called post-racial harmony
with all people in america but us blacks
are being murdered all over the place
and we get the same treatment time and
time again we're not even second-class
citizens we third class
stand up black america and declare the
white america that we aren't going to
take this no more okay why come out now
and say this you know what you have 400
years to get it right america but you
don't know how to treat your people all
people it's time to stand up it's time
to take back it's time for us to fight
back and we don't take your phony words
anymore we're not going to do it we want
concrete results you know you you hear
what we're saying to you united snakes
of america
what are you supposed to do when the
whole world is watching and no one is
saying anything we will not be silent
okay you sir anything you wanted to say
oh me no i'm good
[Music]
hey what up y'all welcome back to hcl we
are in hollywood i got the answers and
the answers this morning is mother
majesty thank you for being here mother
majesty thank you for having me
yeah now before the break we heard your
song uh she nominated from the new hit
album girl army oh yeah yeah
well thank you so much scratch you know
this whole album is about girls and
empowering girls and you know kind of
just showing girls they can be strong
and powerful and do what they want to do
and not what the media says they need to
do
all right all right that's deep that's
deep now we got some uh young females
here we have some questions for you uh
is that okay oh it's always okay it's
always okay i always want to give my
girl army hi majesty it is so cool to
meet you thank you so much i think
you're beautiful just like that um
yeah so okay last week i took your
advice from your song get some and i
flaunted it till they wanted it
but i ended up losing my virginity to a
guy that i don't know you see it is time
for girls to take back the power
nowadays because it's your body and it's
your mind and you should use that to
feel sexy and empowered
okay yeah yeah but now i'm pregnant
miracles next question
hi hi majesty i'm cassie i think your
album rocks thank you so much cassie i
think you should never change your skin
okay
so in your song friday night freak down
thank you so much cassie
you say bend it over touch the ground
he'll ride you like his merry-go-round
yes i do
is that about butt sex what it's about
cassie is us reclaiming our bodies as
women because you know for a long time
being sexy was about being sexy for a
man but this is about being sexy for
yourself
but i've got herpes in my butt okay
let's
change tracks for a second we gonna go
to commercial when we come back mother
majesty is going to unfurl her new song
what is it about oh okay it's a it's
kind of a love song and it's about
finding strength after having your heart
broken all right we gonna go to
commercial when we come back mother
majesty with who got next on this
blackberry pie
here's your dressing room your majesty
thank you so much
[Music]
[Music]
that's right girls being overly sexual
and being strong are the same thing
[Music]
it's the same thing
it's the same
thing
[Laughter]
i'm allergic to this makeup
now why would i have burped
that's weird
[Music]